Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Chaque année en France, nous générons
12 millions de tonnes de déchets
alimentaires qu’on appelle le biodéchet.
Ce sont tous nos restes de repas
qui comprennent des végétaux,
mais aussi des restes
de viande, de poisson.
C'est à peu près un tiers
de nos poubelles grises.
Et pour essayer de visualiser
ces 12 millions de tonnes,
on peut imaginer 400 porte-avions
de type Charles-de-Gaulle
à la queue leu leu, sur 150 kilomètres,
c’est-à-dire la distance
qui sépare Nice de Toulon.
Et à l’échelle de l’UE,
c’est bien plus encore puisqu’on parle
de 100 millions de tonnes.
Et 100 millions de tonnes,
c’est presque dix fois plus que
ce que l’on produit en France par an.
Ces déchets alimentaires
ont l’air inoffensifs
et pourtant ils représentent
un vrai problème pour l’environnement.
Ils sont d’abord le révélateur
d’un gaspillage alimentaire massif.
Pour produire de la nourriture,
on produit fatalement
du dioxyde de carbone.
Et si on pouvait déjà réduire
quelque peu ce gaspillage,
on réduirait également nos émissions.
Envoyés en décharge, ils vont produire
des jus qu’on appelle lixiviat,
qui peuvent s’infiltrer dans la terre
et contaminer les sols
et les nappes phréatiques.
Lorsqu’on les envoie
en incinération, enfin,
ils ne sont d’aucune utilité car brûler
de l’eau n’a jamais produit d’énergie.
Or les déchets alimentaires sont
composés à plus de 70% d’eau.
Pour autant,
ils représentent un potentiel
énergétique et agronomique,
puisqu’une tonne de biodéchets
mis en méthanisation
va produire 100 mètres cubes
de biométhane.
C’est un gaz vert renouvelable.
Et 100 m3 de biométhane,
c’est l’équivalent énergétique pour
parcourir 1000 kilomètres en voiture.
Et en plus de ce biométhane, on produit
également pour toujours une tonne,
à peu près 800 kilos
de fertilisant organique.
C’est pour toutes ces raisons
qu’une réglementation européenne
prévoit désormais
leur tri à la source et leur valorisation
en méthanisation et en compostage.
Donc, c’est une réglementation
qui s’est traduite en droit français.
Elle est déjà applicable
pour tous les gros producteurs,
c’est-à-dire ceux qui font plus
de dix tonnes de biodéchets par an,
une restauration collective
de 300 couverts, par exemple.
Mais à partir du 31 décembre 2023,
c’est vous tous, moi également,
qui devrons trier à la source
ces déchets alimentaires
pour les envoyer dans la bonne filière.
La ville dans laquelle vous habitez
devra vous proposer une solution.
Alors, une fois qu’on a dit ça,
mettre en place une nouvelle collecte,
après le verre, le papier, le carton,
le plastique, le textile, les piles,
ça peut s’avérer un peu compliqué, voire
décourageant pour certaines collectivités
et certains individus.
Cela pose en effet certaines difficultés.
Par exemple, des problèmes
de fréquence de collecte,
des problèmes d’ergonomie,
les déchets sont parfois lourds,
des problèmes d’hygiène,
ils ne sentent pas toujours bons,
des problèmes de qualité matière,
parce qu’on va retrouver aussi beaucoup
de plastique, des sacs, des emballages,
des erreurs de tri dans les déchets,
des problèmes aussi de coûts
et des problèmes naturellement
de motivation.
Mais pour autant, c’est vraiment
quelque chose qu’il faut faire,
parce qu’avec l’urbanisation
qui se développe de plus en plus
et les défis auxquels
nous allons être confrontés,
ce sera difficile de couper court
à une modification de nos comportements.
Alors, pour autant,
des solutions simples,
pragmatiques, locales existent.
Et je vais vous donner un exemple,
celui que nous avons mis en place
dans plusieurs collectivités avec Axibio.
Ce sont des choses simples.
Les gens font le tri de leurs déchets,
les gens, les particuliers,
mais aussi les commerçants.
Une fois qu’ils ont trié,
quand ils veulent,
ils se déplacent
à une borne d’apport volontaire spéciale,
la plus proche de chez eux,
un peu comme pour le textile ou le verre.
Pourquoi l’apport volontaire ?
Eh bien, parce que c’est une solution
bien plus économique
qu’une collecte en porte à porte.
Ces bornes d’apport volontaire sont
équipées d’un contrôle d’accès
et d’une balance, alimentés
à l’énergie solaire.
Les personnes s’identifient
à l’aide d’un badge ou de leur smartphone
et quand elles déposent leurs déchets,
on va enregistrer le poids de ceux-ci
et les associer à un identifiant.
Lorsque le contenant à l’intérieur
de cette borne est plein,
il est acheminé ensuite
vers un site intermédiaire,
un petit site local,
équipé d’un bio-séparateur.
C’est une machine dans laquelle
on va passer tous les biodéchets
et on en va séparer toutes les erreurs
de tri que l’on retrouve
malgré la bonne volonté de tri
des particuliers et des commerçants.
C’est-à-dire qu’on va évacuer les
indésirables comme des pots de yaourts,
des sachets de mayonnaise, des sacs
plastiques, des filets de légumes,
des opercules, des canettes -
on trouve un tas de choses -
de façon à pouvoir fournir
une biomasse pure,
de qualité pour les unités de valorisation
que sont la méthanisation et le compostage
qui doivent respecter des règles strictes
de retour aux sols de ces matières,
où il ne doit figurer aucune impureté.
Alors, dans ce dispositif,
le digital et la pesée
sont d’une aide précieuse
car les particuliers peuvent consulter
sur une application
les quantités de déchets qu’ils produisent
tout au long de l’année
et visualiser la contribution
de leurs déchets
à la production de fertilisants
et d’énergie sur leur territoire.
Et s’ils le souhaitent,
ils peuvent aussi commencer
à surveiller leur gaspillage alimentaire.
Il faut voir que tous ces éléments
permettent de modifier les comportements
et d’embarquer les usagers
dans cette nouvelle collecte
qui peut paraître parfois
un peu compliquée.
La collectivité, de son côté, va pouvoir
visualiser sur son portail web
ce qu’elle produit tout au long de l’année
comme quantité de matière,
par quartier, par commune,
et pouvoir optimiser la distribution
de ces bornes sur son territoire
et optimiser également les collectes.
Et les unités de valorisation peuvent
produire localement de l’énergie
en embarquant la population
dans cette activité
et en ayant une traçabilité
sur les matières.
Ce geste simple de tri
peut avoir un impact considérable
sur l’environnement et sur le climat.
Chacun peut réduire ses gaspillages,
produire de l'énergie décarbonée,
produire des fertilisants renouvelables
avec une gestion saine
et intelligente de ces déchets
que chaque territoire
peut mettre en place.
Demain commence aujourd'hui.
On peut tous agir en ce sens.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)